ونحيكم من جديد في الوقت الذي تتصاعد فيه
الهجمات الاوكرانيه داخل الاراضي الروسيه
الحدوديه نقلت صحيفه
تصريحها بتعرضها لاكبر هجوم تشنه اوكرانيا
في داخل الروسي منذ اشهر وبالتزامن مع
تقرير الصحيفه كشف وزير الدفاع الروسي
انها كيف تشن هجمات على مواقع مختلفه
بالخطوط الاماميه منذ ثلاثه ايام مضيفا ان
القوات الاوكرانيه نفذت هجماتها في خمسه
اتجاهات مختلفه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني كشف
ايضا عن مقتل اكثر من 70 جنديه روسيا في
اليومين الماضيين خلال تصديهم لتلك
الهجمات الاوكرانيه اما جهاز الامن
الفيدراليه الروسي فكان قد تحدث بانه بعد
احتجاز طيارين اثنين من وحده الطيران
التابعه للاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه
اعترف الطيران بالتحضير لهجمات اخرى داخل
روسيا وان المسؤوله في استخبارات اندفاع
الاوكرانيه كيرل بودانوف الوحده الثالثه
لهذا الهدف واضاف الجهاز الفيدرالي
والروسي انا اوكرانيا رسمت خطه لتسليم
ووضع ما يسمى بالقنابل القذره المجهزه
باجهزه تحكم بالوقت لتفجير المناطق
المستهدفه تقارير عسكريه رات انها تزايد
هذه الهجمات على اراضي روسيا الحدوديه
دلاله على ان الهجوم الاوكراني المتوقع قد
بدا فهل بدات كاف هجومها المضاد هذا هو
السؤال
[تصفيق]
نتابع ونناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من
موسكو
الدبلوماسيون السابق اهلا بك ومنك الدكتور
سعيد سلام مدير مركزي فيجن للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام
واسمحوا لي ان ابدا من معك دكتور سعيد
دكتور سعيد سؤال بسيط ولكن نحن نطرحه في
الواقع من فتره لاخرى مع كل تطور عسكري
تقوم به كيف طرحناه حتى فتره لو تتذكر
محاوله استهداف بطائره دون طيار الكرملين
ولكن هذه المره الاخبار تاتي من روسيا
نفسها التي تقول بان كيف
تستهدفها في العمق فسؤال مطروح هل بدا
الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني على روسيا حقا
مساء الخير
اعتقد ان الهجوم المضاد بمفهومه بتقدم
القوات الاوكرانيه البريه لم يبدا حتى
الان ولكن العمليات
التحضيريه لمثل هذا التقدم البري جاريه
منذ عده اسابيع حيث نلحظ تصاعدا كبيرا في
استهداف
المواقع الخلفيه للقوات الروسيه في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه المحتله وخصوصا مواقع
المراكز والقياده
ومخازن
ولكن دكتور سعيد تتحدث حضرتك عن توغل بري
هل يمكن الاكياف ان تفكر في مثل هكذا
يعني استراتيجيه لانه البعض يتحدث عن
طائرات بدون طيار تستهدف لعمق الروسي ولكن
يبدو بان سيناريوهات اوكرانيا
تفوق حتى او تتجاوز خياله البعض
لا طبعا انا اتحدث عن تحرير الاراضي
الاوكرانيه المحتله
منطق الدباس وخرسون وايضا
ولكن وحسب البيانات الاوكرانيه الرسميه
فان القوات الاوكرانيه لا تقوم بعمليات
داخل الاراضي الروسيه وما يجري في منطقه
بيلجر هو عباره عن مجموعه من
المواطنين الروس الملاحظين للنظام في
الكرملين
بعمليات تحرير من النظام الروسي في تلك
المنطقه هذا هي البيانات الرسميه
الاوكرانيه لذلك انا اتحدث عن الهجوم
المضاد الذي سيكون في الاراضي الاوكرانيه
المحتله منذ عام
1914 بما فيها شبه جزيره القرن لذلك هنا
نشهد عمليات كبيره واسعه من لضرب الخطوط
الامداد الاستراتيجيه اكده حتى وهذا ما
اكده حتى وزير الدفاع الروسي سيد فتشيسلاف
وزير دفاع روسي نفسه تحدث عن ان الاوكران
اولا يستهدفون مواقع لم تكن منتظره من
الجانب الروسي وكذلك هم يتوسعون هل هذا
فشل روسي جديد هل اخفقت روسيا في وقف توسع
وتمدد القوات الاوكرانيه
وزير الدفاع الروسي وهو اول مره خلال هذه
الفتره الطويله
لعمليه عسكريه ادلب بتصريح الرسمي وهو قال
انه خلال ثلاث ايام
الماضيه
يعني خلال هذا الاسبوع
كانت هناك بدات هناك
هجوم كما يسمونه هجوم المضاد ولكن هذا
بالروسيه يسمونها هجوم اوكراني على مواقع
قوات روسيه وهو قال انه التقدم كان في عده
الاتجاهات ليس في اتجاه واحد
ونتيجه المعارك اللي كانت جاريه في هذه
الاتجاهات
قوات روسيه دمرت صلاه الاف 718 جندي
اوكرانيا وكذلك 52 دبابه بينها
فرنسيه
وكذلك بريطانيه ضبابه ولكن
الارقام
ولكن ما تعرضه حضرتك من ارقام ضيفي وكانه
يشكك بها خليني افهم منك اكثر دكتور سعيد
تشكك فيها او تعتبر ما يتفضل به ضيفه من
موسكو يعني ليس
اجتهاد او ليس
طبعا مشكك بهذه الارقام لان المبلغات
الروسيه في البيانات العسكريه التي تصدرها
منذ بدايه هذه هذا العدوان الروسي على
اوكرانيا تثير الشفقه بصراحه لانهم عمليا
عمليا قاموا بتدمير اوكرانيا ثلاث مرات
وتدمير يعني ثلاث يعني انظمه من اصل اثنين
حصلت عليها اوكرانيا و44 منظومه من اصل 18
حصلت عليها اوكرانيا وغيرها من هذه
الارقام الهجوم البري لم يبدا بعد هناك
عمليات تقوم بها عمليات ما يسمى العمليات
الاستطلاع العسكري او الاستطلاع الحربي
بالمعارك تقوم بها القوات الاوكرانيه لذلك
تقوم
بهذه العمليات تتم بواسطه قوات ليست كبيره
قبل يتجاوز تعدادها من 300 الى 500 جندي
كحد اقصى ولذلك كيف يمكن مثل هذه العمليات
البسيطه القوات البسيطه
مقتل 3700 جندي مقابل يعني القوات
الاوكرانيه والسلطات الاوكرانيه تصرح عن
تقدم
في
محور من شمال وجنوب المدينه وايضا في
الجنوب الجنوب في محور زابروجيا حسب
المعلومات الروسيه سؤال السيد الجنديه
اقول لك كيف لهذه الكتيبه المكونه من بضعه
اعداد ان تستهدف بالالاف وهنا سؤال هل
هناك اعلاميه تطمح روسيا لوضعها لاخفاق
لاخفاء اخفاقاتها
انا
سمعت من ايه مصدر الروسي ارقام الضحايا
ولا من في جيش الروسي ولا في جيش اوكراني
كل اركان اللي كان نحن نسمع الاوبل كانت
ارقام عرضها على مستمعين
والمشاهدين من قبل محللين والصحفيين وليست
من مصادر الرسميه هذا فرق الكبير مصدر
لانه على مستوى وزير تشويش المعلومات عن
شخصين اعطائنا غير ممكنه ولكن طيب
مهما تكون هذه الارقام اعطتها جهه صحفيه
ولو انك تعلم حضرتك بانه في مثل هيك هكذا
اوقات حساسه هناك ما يسرب كذلك اعلاميا
ولكن نحن امام تصريحات لوزير الدفاع
الروسي هو يقر بان هناك توسع للح ضور
الاوكراني هو توجه الى العمق الروسي
لا يتكلم هو عن عمق وتوجه وتقدم قوات
اوكرانيه هو يتحدث عن
ضحايا عن تدمير بعض المعدات اوكرانيه في
خلال القتال ولا يتناول باي شيخ شكل من
اشكال التقدم لذلك الحصراء تستمر
واذا بدات هذا الهجوم طبعا انا شخصيا
اعتبر ان هجوم قد بضع ولماذا لانه
واضح
تنسيق هو تماما نعم دكتور سعيد باختصار
شديد في 30 ثانيه تعليقك
اقل لم يبدا حتى الان الهجوم المضاد ولكن
تقوم القوات الاوكرانيه بالتحضير المكثف
لهذا الهجوم لذلك يتم سوف نشهد خلال
الاسابيع المقبله يعني اماكن جديده
للتحضيرات وعندما يبدا الهجوم سوف يتراجع
دكتور سعيد سلام شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا كذلك
السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات